so I just posted a Tik Tok talking about
how insane the official Dragon Ball
Twitter has been so let's go again has
anyone noticed the fact that they keep
posting themed tweets like without any
context so they just seem like they're
going extra insane like the deep fried
Tournament of power scan from the last
video was originally posted on the
Japanese Twitter because it was National
good team day but the English account
just kind of posted it without that
context and it comes off hella random or
this one where the Japanese account
posted this Vegeta because it was good
smile day in Japan but the English
account just raw dogs it with a random
ass compliment or this one where the
Japanese account was posting on good
Coupes day what are these Japanese
holidays holy crap and the English
account just comes off like a grandma
posting on their Facebook W I don't know
what to call this specific former comedy
but it just kills me